[Music]
i really really think
you should sit in this seat more often
okay more often you're welcome
you want to trade yeah we can trade for
this one i mean well i don't have an
article but i really feel like
that's just shade then like you know
like when you're hosting like i've never
seen you host
because you're never here one night
exactly so i would like to see you in
the seat more often how did i do
yesterday you did great
you did a really good he's a good host
yesterday was the first time i sat
in a whole session of a day
and what a whole day and i i was just a
guest
you're a good hot seat guest person dude
i was oh thanks
what if i've been hosting like a lot you
should host
did it feel nice i want the power did it
feel nice
you get to sit there and then you can
just watch casey like try to
deliver all the [ __ ] it was actually
really nice to not have to worry about
the next article reporting but it was
also kind of weird
it felt weird because you're so used to
being host i'm so used to being host
i don't know what it feels like to be
cast for an entire day so yesterday was
a little weird
and then i realized how hard it is to
not look at the screen so i was like oh
should i feel for the guest
it's really hard very hard you're just
like you're like don't look at the
screen and i'm like
okay i know and then even though like
because casey wasn't using this
so i was just like oh man i kept looking
like past the screen i'm like
i like hosting it's really fun but i
think i'm more useful
saying stupid [ __ ] about my porno
stories you wanna know why i want you to
see
pretty useful why because in the times
that i have
come back to sit in the seat after you
have sat here
you're actually way more um
way more or less interrupted
because it you're able to relate to what
it feels like to sit here so then you're
able
you're like less interrupting you think
that's the reason why
[Laughter]
i haven't had coffee in a month that's
why oh he's jumping off the walls right
now oh no i'm talking about
even like on thursday when i think oh
yeah on thursday you had no coffee but
you're still like you know joe well my
me being considered
has nothing to do with me being
considerate so it has nothing to do with
me hosting
it has more to do with me
saying 2020 is the year that i don't
interrupt two
nice we're in like almost august i know
it's been eight
[Music]
i'm so used to it like i'm kind of
desensitized to it honestly if it
if it wasn't you it would be anybody
yeah because yesterday i kept
interrupting hell [ __ ] yeah
yeah so that's what i'm saying if you if
you sit here no one could interrupt me
you relate a little bit better they do
interrupt me though
you know what people constantly
interrupt me when i'm host yep they're
trying to play
games trying to talk about other [ __ ]
the host is you're just bound to be
interrupted
yeah yeah no i mean it's not even the
interruption really it's like
the like the the tools he uses to
[Laughter]
interrupt
there's another layer to it that i think
um it ends up creating a sense of
empathy because sometimes like sitting
in the seat it gets a little
like you get a little in your head
there's anxiety you're trying to like
wrinkle a lot of things in your brain
and then so like whenever
someone else is sitting here and then
they become the cast then they will be
like
oh i know what that feels like so i i
i'll take a step back
and it's nice as a host you know because
it's like cool
everyone gets them like i think
hosting's fun feel the the
the pressures or whatever i think
everyone should host like we should all
take a turn hosting that's what i'm
saying
anthony wants to host yeah yeah i got a
host because i feel like i'm
exercising these neck muscles a lot i
bounce it out
oh yeah every single time she has like
read a whole article i'm trying to be
respectful i'm like
you know you're practically the only
guest that actually like
looks at me this week yeah why almost
everyone because it's just easier to
face this way
that makes sense because i hear better
with the ear directly
but you know like your chair swivels
i think it's just weird to like turn my
knees towards her
i am now optimizing my swivel because
you're also trying to no i feel like you
know
you're trying to favor the camera too
now i got to turn this because
you know what i mean like just face that
way and then you can exercise the other
neck muscles this way
but you can look at me this way but if i
want to look at you look this way
i can't turn right gotta go like this
what you gotta do the magnum what did
you say or magnet
or whatever
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you're saying like magna don't
you guys next hurt from
always sitting in the same seats because
i feel like when when we shoot and if
i'm here for like two or three days
straight
and if i'm sitting here all the time my
neck hurts from always just
turning only one way so sometimes i'll
i'll turn this way just so i can like
fix my next my neck problems i don't
have much
no i mean i'm very fidgety because i'm
always correcting
my body we know this i think that
because of that reason
like i'm always comfortable
yeah true if you're here like this in
one's one position you're gonna go home
like this yeah
and they're like jordan oh my neck i was
too polite and i'm like man [ __ ]
[ __ ] politeness dude i gotta stretch i
gotta move
his box just through his shorts like get
your barbell shorts
get your we sold out
of course i don't wear underwear i'm
just being presentable you just saw his
nuts
like just pure nuts i wear underwear
because i'm being classy today
usually i don't wear underwear with
these shorts so you get a nice breeze
don't know what to say to that that
sounds like so good breathe
no i'm being considerate because
just in case my shorts get hiked
wait but i thought you said you're not
being considered because you're being
considerate
so then why are you being considerate
it's not because you're being
considerate
considerate i don't know what that means
that's what you said
you said that i'm using your own words i
said
because anthony's here today
when i do this stuff he might see my
balls
so i wore underwear to be polite it's
kind of like a junior high girl that
wears
uh spandex under her skirt because it's
not that age
where people should be looking yet and i
really appreciate it
i really appreciate how you already
assumed i will not even be looking in
that direction so it's mainly for
anthony because he would be looking in
your
ball direction because you're usually
too busy remembering the articles
so i already think ahead whereas me i'm
always looking in this way
so i have a lot of ball time too just
kind of and i matched
his kenja oh that's thai
camouflage yeah he knew yeah i can't
wendy's yep
those look comfy actually thank you
they're uh
i got them from a brand deal oh yeah and
it
makes sure that your balls don't stick
to your thigh
it's like a two pocket thing they could
guarantee that i don't know if it's
guaranteed but
it's um i forgot the name of the brand
it cups your balls but there's two brand
new
i did it two years ago it's okay
straight up i was just talking to mike
song the other day mike singh and we
brought up you
and he's like man i'm inspired by joe i
was like oh why he's like dude that full
log he don't give up
[ __ ] man this was just like look at him
he was just like shirtless selling
mushrooms right now on his instagram
like what is going on i'm like yeah dude
he's like he's
good at not giving a [ __ ] he's got his
own island no no no no no i am very i'm
uh i'm
probably the most self-conscious person
you will ever meet
it's just compared to who i don't think
the world takes it that way though yeah
but you know why
it's because he doesn't even take it
that way the world
cares about things that don't matter you
know i'm self-conscious about other
things like
oh my god are people gonna like my
mushrooms i hope the quality is good
enough
i hope that we're doing an ethical job
so that when people eat it
they get the freshest ingredients i'm
self-conscious about [ __ ] like that
oh are videos good yes they're good
they're making people laugh
thank god okay great but not about your
your actual present your appearance
i don't know that's their problem
because the funny thing is when people
think
most regular people when they want to
sell their mushrooms and they want to
care how to perceive
they go okay i'll wear a suit
and i'm promoting my mushrooms and i'll
talk in a very
present way would you like to buy my
mushrooms joe's like how do people
receive my mushrooms
i'll tie my hair up right here
he goes yup for sure they proceeded the
right way
hey because i'm all about the quality
right when they bite into that
[ __ ] they know it's fresh
that's why it does it doesn't matter
what matter huh had mushrooms taste like
bad mushrooms the ones that come out of
cow feces no no
don't those make it high i wouldn't know
well if it's not rotten
over time the taste is weaker
so it's tasteless so it tastes less like
because to me mushrooms have like a
dirt taste not like like like a pizza
pleasant dirt taste earthy some do yeah
you're right
um yeah but you'll be able to tell
because i'll hook you up
i mean you said you grew the oyster
mushrooms and you said the older ones
weren't as good as the younger ones
right oh nice
yeah well you know what mushrooms i
ordered with postmates which one
shitake no uh enoki inoki
my favorite things is i like tofu i like
napa cabbage
and i like enoki and then sometimes when
i go to the grocery store i buy the meat
and i buy the veggies
and then i'm like ready to make shabu
i'm like oh [ __ ]
i forgot my mushrooms and i can't have
my mushrooms without that
the last time i ordered enoki through
postmates and they brought it to my
house
that's so convenient because sometimes
you can't leave the house to grab
groceries yeah
and you're in the middle of cooking you
got [ __ ] stoves and [ __ ] on yeah last
week
uh my girlfriend thought she had rona so
we had to order everything like
groceries food
through postmates she thought she had
rona yeah do postmates that's cool
and you know what no more trips to the
store baby or late night fast food runs
because postmates got your
back yep you could download the
postmates on ios or
android and find your favorites you can
get anything you want delivered within
the hour okay so for limited time
postmates is giving our listeners
100 of free delivery credit for your
first seven days
to start your free deliveries download
the app and use the code
off the record that's called ah the
record
for 100 of free delivery credit with no
minimum purchase for your first seven
days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need anytime you need it
postmates and now you got to do this to
sell it really suck there we go
i like it you know what's funny that um
when people tell me i hear that a lot
right they'll be like oh man
you seem like you don't give a [ __ ] this
is so cool
and all this and i'm all like is there
something that i should be
aware about right now that no one is
telling me about
because they're all telling me like it's
a skill they're all like man i'm so
proud of you man
and i'm all like wait am i doing
something shameful
it's not shameful no no no no no
literally the opposite you're inspired
you're so free it's like it's like a
it's like steve jobs right
remember how everybody was always just
like this will show up in the same
[ __ ] black turtleneck or whatever in
his jeans
he's got billions of dollars or whatever
but he like doesn't care at all but it's
funny because
that's what makes himself that's what
makes him self-conscious
because if for me i'm just like hold the
[ __ ] up
am i doing something inappropriate right
now because i think
i sh i feel like i should be wearing a
shirt now because everyone's saying no
no no no no no what's what's so hard
about mike song adopting the joe
lifestyle
what what's like what are the steps what
are the obstacles earlier when you were
talking about regular people you did
this
because i'm with joe that's what i'm
saying i'm more joe than i am
anomaly i'm just saying it's worse than
me i don't go and do i gotta throw me on
the bus
i don't take out the trash in my
underwear they're trying to be normal
now they're like no he's worse than me
i say i say normal because i'm more with
joe right so i
understand where he's coming from and
that's how i live my life which i take
out the trash and underwear and stuff
so when i say normal people because i
feel like i'm like
on this side of the room and i and i
view people and i'm like
hmm and i do understand what joe's
saying we're like so to me it's like why
is it so hard for someone
to not give a [ __ ] when it's the easiest
i think there are invisible societal
concepts of rules
yeah yeah uh it's like um for better or
for worse right it's like uh
the idea uh let's just take the theme
for example when you're scrolling
through instagram you see like the best
parts of everybody's lives
so you get triggered in this way where
it's like oh man i only want to
share the best things and then you're
insecure about certain things you know
because there's like social media
concept that like has just
blanketed like this is how society
should be when i'm scrolling i know it's
show and tell lie edition
exactly so i know everyone is just lying
and telling their best part of the lie
and so i don't ever get over committed
to which is when you see
something and it's not about good bad
shameful or not i think when you see
something just
[ __ ] authentic just like that's real
yeah that's like really who that person
is it's not a lie yeah that's when
you're like oh damn
that's inspiring and joe's version so my
son can't stop lying
i think my pictures aren't professional
enough so when i
if i had if i get better cinematography
in my
vlogs and pictures then they'll be like
oh
what a facade so nicer pictures of that
haircut right now well no it's it's like
this
i'm in a transitional face guys
it looks tight it looks like a mushroom
actually oh
this is my mushroom favorite campaign
you got to think about like joe's brando
right like
um he's coined a word like mutta right
he's got his own [ __ ] island where
he's a dictator
uh he's able to uh rally and galvanize a
bunch of like different
people out there in the social media
world to like draw pictures of him
kim jong-un's like sister or whatever
you know what i mean there's like
people are like it's incredible it's
like we're
all a part of a joke together
that's the thing like i don't know
i think some people think i'm serious
though but i'm also having a great
[ __ ] time
yeah i think it's impressive is all i'm
saying i think it's it's
it's really really good yeah are you not
serious
what do you mean what depends on
everything i'm so are you saying that
this is a facade no yeah
no no no i'm serious about play i'm
serious about play
but i'm very serious about making a
mockery of
a lot of things that are happening in
the world and
so it's inspiring people don't have that
uh ability sometimes or that voice even
if they might have those
thoughts oh i would say that not
everybody is
as compelled to be able to enjoy life in
that same vocal manner
and you do a very good job of it thank
you but when when people do
wake me up to the real world because i
get so serious about my play
my reality gets skewed right or i don't
know
but then when it gets there nobody gets
cute
it does exception dude mind blown
because what is reality if
if a lot of people just agree that it's
real then it's real
because because most people believe it
right so then i'm like okay
well i'm playing a little too much right
now so
i should be kind of grounded a little
bit and then when i hear things like
that's like oh you worked so hard
to not giving a [ __ ] and i'm like wait a
minute i'm supposed to give a [ __ ] right
now what am i not
what am i missing right now what should
i skip the [ __ ] giving
yeah because it's not a skill it's just
like a disability yeah
be could be could be slightly
appropriate i think it's also just part
of the genius though yes
behind who the person that joe is
because it's like he just does whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to do
and it all makes sense and it's
authentic to him and then i feel like
you know i think sometimes for other
people on social media it's almost like
you view people
as if uh like oh look at this animal in
a cage
right but then from joe's perspective
it's like wait
i'm on a pedestal and you're paying to
see me
so it's like it's like he completely
flips it so you think i'm the monkey in
the cage
but you guys are humans bowing down to
me this is awesome give me my bananas
you're close you're closing that realm
well i think i'm close
in that realm but i'm not i feel like so
if this is a spectrum right this is like
normal people this is joe i don't even
know why he's laughing because i touch
you
you're good at you're good at fitting in
but that's not
you are more like me than what you put
portray on instagram because you have a
you have a not no not that you're a liar
but you
understand what it takes to be a part of
society
and you play that game for your business
for your family
all that stuff be not saying that it's
fraudulent like the way i'm saying is he
understands the
marketing and how it all goes in circle
i understand it i just choose to
sabotage myself
that's that's the part that i'm talking
about
that's exactly what it is you understand
it and then
i give like two [ __ ] more than joe so
i'm like right here
and then it's like the rest of those are
that's 200 more [ __ ] yeah
yeah but i mean i mean i i think um
it's bad because i do know it
but my impulsive nature goes against it
and then i lose money but is it really
bad though in the grand scheme of things
because it's making you money too but it
also hurts
because sometimes i want to do something
so bad and then i do it
and i'm like maybe that wasn't the best
thing for the world to do i mean but
that's
everybody always yeah i think it better
in the holistic perspective to be able
to
more times than not do what you are able
and wanting to do without hurting other
people if you hurt yourself doing it i
mean it's just a part of [ __ ] life
right
as long as you're not really hurting
other people i'm i'm really inspired by
people who can
give less [ __ ] in a world where i mean
we're in like a canceled culture world
right now even too you know what i'm
saying and i'm sure so a lot more people
have started
giving way more [ __ ] than too many
[ __ ] yeah being way too woke i'm trying
to be like
perfectly half asleep i'm in a reduction
of [ __ ] i ain't trying to be overly
welcome i'm trying to be perfectly
drowsy
you know what it is it's not about not
giving the [ __ ]
it's strategizing your [ __ ] yes yes it
is actually
it's a subtle art i deeply care a lot
jazzy [ __ ] i deeply care a lot
i just don't give a [ __ ] what you think
about what i wear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you